how much time do you spend thinking
about the various streaming services out
there and who you want to sell to do you
make the decision I go heavy netflix I
go light amazon that work it's a very
good question we meet constantly and we
have these things called the content
value value meetings which is that where
where do we sell to how do you slice and
dice it do you sell the show to Netflix
what is our European strategy of the
show do we put it on CBS all access
which is our own service etc etc to
maximize the revenue and right now the
business is great as long as we continue
producing great content on showtime on
CBS on the CW we're going to be fine so
if I CBS all access yes if I run that
business do I not walk into your office
and say less please don't sell those
shows keep them here oh yeah the guy the
guy who runs all access is saying that
he's changing and all those meetings
every day don't sell to netflix now I
have another guy who sells to Netflix
saying please Netflix has offered us a
zillion dollars for these 12 shows this
is a great package or Amazon or Hulu
let's sell it there then I got another
guy these were women they've been
working together hahaha that's we have
lots of women working we've mentioned
CBS all XX a couple of times yeah you
announced that I think just after HBO
did there okay a day later daily okay
well you this is direct customer to
consume rectify silver CBS programming
they pay a subscription fee and they get
it directly I haven't heard much since
then how is that going I mean how many
subscribers do you have how large is it
in your business portfolio we we don't
mention numbers yet it is less than a
few months old we are very pleased with
how it's going and this is how we view
the world the current linear system you
get 180 channels we get paid advertising
we get paid retransmission fees for that
then if people get tired of that people
get tired of paying for channels they
don't watch so there's something new
called the skinny bundle where you pay
for only the 12 to 15 channels that you
watch every month and we will get paid a
higher amount okay then you go to one
channel CBS all access which is
basically a la carte will you check off
the five channels you want to watch and
you pay us five ninety-nine a month not
only you get CBS live you get every
episode of every show on the air all the
way back to the beginning and you get
our entire libraries and include sports
but know it well I shouldn't say it
doesn't include the NFL it does include
the other sport we talk these these
streaming services talk about their
great value they have so much data when
Netflix knows it takes three and a half
episodes to hook me to watch 78 episodes
in a row do they share that data with
you of course not of course not that you
know having that debt data knowledgeable
to them is what is more important to
them and not to share once again Netflix
is now in the business of producing
their own content as well so as much as
I love them as a buyer of my content
they're also competitor with me
producing the right exactly isn't that a
problem because essentially they're
having the direct relationship with the
customer that you give up I don't I
don't look they were friend and they're
also competitive as as are most of the
companies out in the universe comcast
right they air CBS but they also own NBC
which is our biggest competitor so
that's the way the world is and you have
to learn to get along with your
competitors how close are you to a deal
with Apple people as consumers love
Apple but when you talk to businesses
that have had or looked at partnering
with them it ain't easy to partner with
out look out there apple is having
conversations with everybody about doing
their own streaming services we've had
those conversations as have the other
network do I think something will happen
probably but I don't know when